[Music]
tonight on brian ross investigates a
summer of reckoning for a billionaire
with powerful friends who thought he got
away with it
Epstein is alleged to have abused
thousands of victims by causing them to
engage in sex acts with him at his
mansion in New York and at his estate in
Palm Beach Florida for the leader of a
church that claims five million members
alleged to have abused his teenaged
followers the type of crimes that belong
nowhere in our society for a beloved and
trusted swimming coach will there
finally be justice for dozens hundreds
of vulnerable victims we were underage
we were little girls how could this go
on for so long before anyone tried to
stop it
too often adults in our society have
turned a blind eye to this type of
criminal behavior alleged here plus our
shoutout for the Miami Herald reporter
whose stories help make sure the voices
of his young victims were finally heard
someone's finally understanding that we
weren't prostitutes we were girls from
the law in crime Network studios in New
York City's Herald Square this is Brian
Ross investigates
good evening and welcome tonight the
summer of reckoning for some very
powerful men accused of the repugnant
sexual abuse of underage victims
religious leaders trusted coaches and
doctors and now this week
multimillionaire by the name of Jeffrey
Epstein arrested on sex trafficking
charges by the FBI as he stepped off his
private jet outside New York he pleaded
not guilty and will be back in court
next week
his lawyers arguing today he should be
released on bail prosecutors said there
were dozens of victims and they issued a
plea for more victims to come forward
victims voices including the many voices
of Epstein's alleged victims must be
heard if you believe you are a victim of
it and Jeffrey Epstein or you have
evidence or information leading to the
content alleged in the indictment
unsealed today we want to hear from you
please call 1-800-425-9899 derails
prosecutors said there were hundreds if
not thousands of such photos all the
more amazing because Epstein has
supposedly put all this behind him when
he got a sweetheart deal from federal
prosecutors in Miami pleading guilty to
a minor state charge that required him
to serve only about a year behind bars
in the county jail that actually allowed
him to go to his office everyday yet he
kept those photos carefully
labeled and hidden it is safe hardly the
actions of a man who had learned the
errors of his way from his earlier brush
with the law
apparently counting on his powerful and
well-connected friends to overlooked
what he had done to often adults in our
society have turned a blind eye to this
type of criminal behavior alleged here
we have seen the excuses the ignorance
of many who didn't even bother to
understand that this behavior is this
persistent scourge against our society's
vulnerable youth and the willful
blindness is to who the real villains
are in this type of outrageous crime the
villains are the adult perpetrators not
the children
as for Epstein's powerful friends they
were running for cover in the wake of
his arrest President Trump now says he
never had a friendship with Epstein woo
him like everybody in Palm Beach knew I
mean people in Palm Beach knew him he
was a fixture in Palm Beach I had a
falling-out with him a long time ago I
don't think I've spoken to him for 15
years I wasn't a fan I was not yeah a
long time ago I'd say maybe 15 years I
was not a fan of his but earlier Trump
had told New York Magazine I've known
Jeff for 15 years terrific guy he's a
lot of fun to be with and added it's
even said he likes beautiful women as
much as I do and many of them are on the
younger side no doubt about it
Jeffery enjoys his social life President
Clinton who traveled frequently on
Epstein's private jet had his office
issue its own statement that Clinton
knows nothing about the allegations and
that any travel with Epstein was
connected to the work of the Clinton
Foundation as for Prince Andrew of
England seen here in this photo with a
then sixteen-year-old girl who claims in
court papers she was one of Epstein sex
slaves there has been no comment from
the palace the prince had earlier denied
he had sex with the young woman joining
us now to talk about Epstein and the
other prominent men facing similar
charges is Janet Rosen's fight the
executive director of the American
professional Society of the abuse of
children author of the sex-wise parents
a guide for parents talking with their
children about sexual predators and
use this one sorry thank you for joining
us what do you make of all these
prominent men now facing this reckoning
they it's about time that we recognize
the impact this kind of behavior has on
kids it's about time that we recognize
that all kids are valuable that there's
not threat there there's no such thing
as a throwaway kid and I think what's
happening now kind of you know what wake
of the b-two movement is finally we're
being able to talk openly and honestly
about sex about sexuality in ways that
blow the cover from these guys because
in our culture when we don't talk about
sex when parents can't talk to their
kids or don't talk to kids about their
sex we're given the bad guys cover and
it's about time that cover is gone dr.
Rosen swag these sexual predators are
known to groom their victims how do they
look for a victim what are they looking
for well if they're smart they're
looking for kids that are going to be
vulnerable but there's all kinds of
vulnerability some one of the most
common kinds of vulnerability
particularly with young girls is when
they don't understand their own
sexuality when kids are raised without
any kind of understanding about human
sexual response about what their bodies
do as an autonomic natural response to a
feeling or a stimuli kids particularly
girls can be at risk of mistaken sexual
arousal for love or something more
important than that and men that are
trying men can exploit that they can
exploit that ignorance they can exploit
that vulnerability and then we find
these kids thinking that it was it was
love that was real it was something more
important finding out it was nothing
more than a financial transaction which
leaves them devastated then we've got to
deal with folks deal you know with
trauma going into their adult lives dr.
Rosen so I got questions for you from
our control room from executive producer
Rhonda Schwartz so what can parents or
adults do to protect their children
that's a great question probably one of
the most important things parents need
to be doing and starting from as young
as possible when it's age-appropriate to
make sure they talk about sex and
sexuality and bodies and relationships
as part of everyday life one of the
things we
fine along with the lack of information
about sexuality is you know the
offenders
somehow managed to become grown human
beings who have no or little regard for
the feelings of other human beings so as
well as parents working to raise kids
that understand sexuality in their
bodies that's one way we can you know
that's a great protective factor against
victimization but it's a really
important protective factor about
against raising a perpetrator is to
teach kids empathy to teach kids to
understand the impact of their behaviors
on other people I mean the very same
concepts that we talk about with
bullying prevention we look at these
guys that we're talking about in the
show tonight
and we've got bullying taken to an
absolutely horrendous extreme dr. Rosen
saw one of the amazing things about the
charges against the epstein where the
extent to which his aides helped him
recruit other young women and the young
women themselves helped recap I know
it's about social norms people learn to
accept things as normal as accepted
without questioning it and broadcast
like this one or shows like this one in
efforts like this one we have to change
the social norms to make it clear that
there's no such thing as underage women
they're children there's no such thing
as a child prostitute it's a victim
we've got to change the social norm and
the me2 movement of starting that so
that nobody accepts this nobody accepts
that it's par for the course to solicit
kids for their boss because that makes
them happy dr. brothers are staying with
us now because when we come back after
our break we're gonna talk about another
prominent person who also is facing
similar charges the leader of a church
claiming to have 5 million members also
under arrest on charges he abused
underage girls telling them they were
doing right by God
we're back now with our special reporter
and what has become a summer of
reckoning for some powerful men accused
of the sexual abuse of underage victims
in sports we've reported here on the
ongoing scandal at USA Swimming hundreds
of coaches banned because of alleged
sexual abuse of young swimmers with new
cases still coming in the outrage
continues over similar allegations
involving USA Gymnastics and the team
doctor dr. Larry Nasser who used his
position of power to molest and abuse
dozens of youngsters and in the world of
religion the stories of abuse seem to
never end
most recently involving the leader of a
church which claims to have 5 million
members active it says yet all 50 states
plus 58 countries around the world
[Music]
King Garcia began his career as a
minister in Arizona and Southern
California before taking over as the
leader of a church that calls itself the
light of the world claiming members in
58 countries
he teaches that he is the apostle of
Jesus Christ one week before he was
arrested on sex trafficking and abuse
charges he warned his devoted followers
that those who would oppose him were
like a cancer
one week later the apostle of Jesus was
under arrest in Los Angeles the
California Attorney General calling him
sick and demented the type of crimes
that belong nowhere in our society from
human trafficking production of child
pornography the Attorney General said
the beloved church leader was provided
by his followers with images of teenage
girls who were told to quote take off
their clothing touch each other's
breasts and vaginas and lick whipped
cream off each other's breasts unquote
they were parishioners if you wish to
call them that this is a it's a pretty
large organization I hesitate to call it
a church mega church and it has a lot of
followers and these are some people
would probably call this a case of
brainwashing or where these families are
influenced with their leader the apostle
of Jesus Christ behind bars awaiting
trial members of the church were
instructed to pray for joaquin garcia
the false allegations leveled against
her church leader apostle NOS own
joaquin garcia have caused our church a
deep sadness however our church
community is confident the allegations
will be proven false and we continue our
conversation now with dr. jenna
rosensweig author of the sex-wise
parents a guide to help parents protect
their children and dr. Rosen's wife
thank you for joining us let me ask you
these are men of incredible power and
influence there's a sense of trust they
have that they ask their followers to
trust them mm-hmm yes and what followers
should be trusting is their own faith
and their own spirituality but they
should be trusting their own instincts
about what's right and what's wrong and
the values that they grew up with the
values that they learned somewhere deep
inside the parents of these kids are the
kids these set themselves have a sense
that this isn't right that this isn't
what's supposed to happen and the these
folks empower these folks in authority
get so good at manipulating
violating them to get rid of their own
judgment that's why I think it's so
critical and I'm consistently urging
parents to keep the communication open
with their kids
there is no mainstream Western religion
that does not recognize the right and
responsibility for parents to talk to
their kids about sex and sexuality and
when they're part of the fundamentalist
movement or a religious organization
that tries to silence them on that topic
what that silence does once again is it
gives the bad guys cover and doctor how
do these leaders achieve that silence
how do they persuade their young victims
to stay quiet
well one of the things they do is they
convince them that what they're doing is
special that what they're doing is
private they convince them that this
relationship is going to make them very
special and make them make them private
then that the gifts to the point what
some some abusers do they manage to
elicit a sexual response from a child
you know an orgasm or even almost orgasm
and then they convince the child they
were complicit and when a child is
trapped like that particularly this
happens to boys when a child is trapped
like that into believing not only
something bad happened to them but
what's wrong with me because I liked it
that sets the stage for later mental
health issues when something that they
know is wrong actually ends up feeling
good and molesters abusers take
advantage of that and if kids understand
that this is just what bodies do that
arousal and responses as autonomic is
getting goosebumps when they're cold boy
is that a protective factor against that
kind of lying and manipulation doctor do
you blame the parents at all of the
young victims no I don't blame parents
particularly this generations parents
because this generation of parents came
of age in the 80s and 90s when they
probably got very little sex information
in school the folks that are parenting
kids now grew up in the abstinence only
age where you know parents that went to
school in the 60s and 70s had a much
stronger background in human sexuality
and sexual health than the parents that
went to school in the 80s and 90s
and one of the ways we can do this and
that's organized religion and organized
youth serving agencies some of them are
doing fabulous jobs reaching out to
parents and families to help them
promote sexual health and safety and if
there's any silver lining to this awful
awful summer of reckoning as you're
calling it it's how many organizations
are stepping forward and recognizing
what they can do to help keep kids and
families safe and quickly we just have
30 seconds do you think there'll be more
victims coming forward now with all the
coverage of these events I can only hope
that more victims come forward because
we know from retrospective studies what
a huge number of victims there are out
there
and as organizations incidents like this
one help let kids know it was not their
fault help let kids know they were nip Y
elated by people with more power I hope
more victims come forward and people are
there to catch them dr. Jenna Rosen's
like thank you so much for joining us
and thank you for your insights coming
up our shoutout for the Miami Herald
reporter who helped to expose the kid
gloves treatment of accused trafficker
Jeffrey Epstein it was her work that
gave a voice to his many victims
and our shutout tonight is for Julie
Brown the Miami Herald reporter whose
investigation into the Jeffrey Epstein
case helped to spark the outrage over
the handling of this affair by federal
authorities including Alexander Acosta
who resigned just today as the Secretary
of Labor because of his handling of the
epstein prosecution we first highlighted
Browns work on our very first edition of
Brian Ross investigates well before all
the recent developments and it's worth
taking a look again today a shout out to
the Miami Herald for its explosive
investigation into how this billionaire
convicted sex offender Jeffrey Epstein
was able to get what was essentially a
slap on the wrist for abusing dozens of
underage girls we didn't really know how
many there were
I mean part of this story is how much
was kept secret in in the court
documents reporter Julie Brown spent
more than a year tracking down the young
women who were Epstein's victims I
probably spoke with about eight and of
those eight only four wanted to go on
the you know courageous enough to go on
the record in a powerful video Brown
produced with her partner Emily miss
show we were underage we were little
girls I was 16 I was 16 I started going
to him when I was like 14 15 14 turning
15 if you think at 14 $200 that's a lot
of money at 14 years olds I mean that's
a lot of money now and then Brown spent
countless hours doing journalism the old
fashioned tried-and-true way to learn
about the lenient deal federal
prosecutors cut with Upstate requiring
him to serve only 13 months in a County
Jail these are 10 to 12 years worth of
documents there was probably thousands
if not tens of thousands of documents to
wade through but the turning point came
Brown says when two key police officials
trusted her enough to lay out what
really happened behind the scenes it
started out and given me in a back road
but many cases it turned into something
far worse than that elevated to a crime
and a serious crime what he had lead to
was a joke
the sentence he serves it was even a
bigger joke and then his probation was a
slap in everybody's face I think once
the police chief was willing to go on
the record with me and the lead
detective both of them had never given
interviews before and I think after we
did their interviews we really realize
how how good of a story we had and it
went to the heart of how much influence
Epstein had and how he and his the
people that work for him bullied
everyone associated with this case and
look who knows what else is going to
come out I mean that the excellent
journalism is now has spread the message
it's not just a state court case that
stuck in Palm Beach County now people
are really aware of what's going on
Browns reporting raised questions about
the federal prosecutor at the time Alex
Acosta who is now the Secretary of Labor
in the Trump administration he seemed to
go to great lengths to cut a lenient
deal with Epstein and keep the whole
process secret
according to Brown Acosta defended the
deal during his Senate confirmation
hearings this that mr. Epstein should
plead guilty to two years register as a
sex offender and concede liability so
that victims could get restitution and
if that were done the federal interest
would be satisfied and we would defer to
the state Brown got no comment from
Epstein nor did we but one of his
lawyers Alan Dershowitz told me he was
proud of the deal he made for his client
so no regrets then in arranging a deal
in which he spent only 13 months behind
spent only ten months I mean the job of
criminal defense lawyers to get the best
possible deal if I had been able to get
him in the / he spent no time in prison
that would have been even better members
of Congress have now asked for a full
investigation of the deal in the wake of
Julie Browns reporting and she is
continuing on the story knowing that her
efforts made a difference and gave
Epstein John victims
a sense of justice that the Department
of Justice did not they were made to
believe that they were prostitutes so
they finally said someone's finally
understanding that we weren't
prostitutes we were girls he violated us
maybe now something will change I think
they're still hoping for for a sense of
justice that something will be done in
the case since we first gave Julie Brown
a shout-out the Epstein case has become
a major story including the new charges
against him which could put Epstein in
prison for the rest of his life if found
guilty as well as today's resignation by
Labor Secretary Acosta over his handling
of the case which came despite his
claims he had acted entirely
appropriately power of investigative
reporting the story of the year Epstein
will be back in court next week and will
continue our coverage here on the law
and crime Network that's our program for
tonight thanks for joining us we'll see
you back here next week